hi how are you i'm so good how are you i
don't know why i felt compelled to say
that
like we were at a boxing match i feel
like i should get up
and have like a sign with a sash and
like round
15. gabriel
fluffy glaciers
[Music]
you have no idea what you just did for
me um
you have such a large following people
really
like fall on the sword for your words
and
i love when people are you know
very um beloved by kids
and adults which is not an easy thing to
do
and be able to be raw and funny and
truthful
and that is not an easy line to walk and
yet you do
it's that whole uh trying to be like
shrek
or it's like you're edgy enough for the
parents but still fun enough for the
kids but you're right there where
you don't cross that line i always let
the people know hey
i'm not here to offend i'm here to
entertain here to have a good time
and uh if at the end of the show you
feel good and you'd like to invite
other people to come out to the shows
next time please do that for me you guys
are my voice
i'm not trying to ruffle feathers i'm
trying to bring people together not
separate people
what do you think that means like comedy
in 2020
with everything that's happening in the
world not only is it hard to
transcend the ages but this year in
particular
are there rules are there do's and
don'ts
because you're obviously very sensitive
to that
i am very sensitive to that my only
rules have have been
uh for the shows don't talk about uh
politics
religion or sports and you should be
okay
the more you you share stories about
engaging with people as opposed to
pushing people away i think that you
know that that warms up
audiences and people want to just have
more of that i don't want you leaving
the show
questioning your life and and what
should i think and what should i believe
i just want you leaving the show going
man that was a good time i can't wait to
go get something to eat
let's let's learn to you know i know we
can't really hug each other right now
because you know
for obvious reasons but i mean we want
to bring people together and
and remind uh everyone that this is a
time to care about one another
when the pandemic started um you you had
been touring and
is it hard not to tour because i'm like
you i want to be with people
luckily i'm with this awesome team that
i work with every day and we're so happy
to be together
um but that must be hard if you're a
people person or a bringer together
yeah we were in the middle of uh the
biggest tour i've i've had and
we were in kalamazoo michigan and that
was the day we got the uh
you know we got the phone call i got had
a meeting on the tour bus and they said
basically they're pulling the plug after
tonight and we got to go home and it's
like what
and so you know i i want to say that i
had one of my best shows ever
because i knew that it was going to be a
while before i touched the stage again
missing it is an understatement you know
i was on a stage every single night
and so to go from that to getting a lot
of sleep that i didn't know i needed
[Laughter]
but yeah it was a it was a shocker and a
half for me i had to learn to readjust
yeah um is it true that you were almost
a teacher
i had the opportunity to become a
teacher uh
almost means that that was like i was
gonna make it happen and then all of a
sudden stand up comedy gotten in the way
and
and took it over um i took a course in
high school called exploratory teaching
and uh i didn't know that i was really
good at it you know it's one of those
things where
you get a grade for one thing but being
able to get in front of people and
connect
that's not something really that you
know there's you know how do you teach
that
and they told me that i had a a gift for
being in front of kids and getting their
attention and they said if you can get
their attention
you can teach them and uh you know
obviously
other things kind of got in the way and
uh that's that's why i'm here
well thank goodness that they did and
then you play
a teacher on mr iglesias
and that's so cool that you're a teacher
in your job
and the the most amazing part is that my
the school teacher who
influenced me who influenced me the most
her name is june garner
who was my speech teacher in high school
and she's the one who would push me and
encourage me to enter speech tournaments
and
she says you're funny you need to just
get up there and i really hated writing
stuff down
and she says well just memorize your
your your monologue
and i'll i'll i'll take you to the she
would drive me to these
functions and um she was able to attend
all of the tapings
of mr iglesias and i had uh i thought
that she had
passed away a few years ago because
that's what they told me i'd lost touch
with her
and my buddy juan he uh he found her and
he
brought her to the show and i had no
idea that you know that she was there
and so we had we reconnected at the
actual premiere of mr iglesias
and uh we've uh we've been in touch
since did you say
i'm so glad you're alive and i'm playing
a teacher
you know she's a little more old school
she was more like you know uh blankety
blank blank clank
who told you that that i was dead uh and
i'm like
sorry well she sounds like my kind of
lady
um well my kids and i obviously
love unleashed uh what an amazing
show i bet right here drew
oh no oh no
oh my goodness he has my dog douglas has
a tongue that hangs out the side of his
mouth too
this is risa it's like lisa with an r
and she is 16 years old
see i had my two dogs here but funny
enough i had to send them home because
we have some visitors here on the set
we're going to take a quick break but
when we come back can we do some
extraordinary
animal acts with you i think we can
oh this is going to be so fun
[Music]
you